soy edurne pasabán alpinista Española y
soy la primera mujer en el mundo que
consiguió escalar las 14 montañas más
altas de la tierra los 14-8 miles
[Música]
Bueno la verdad es que no había mucho
referentes femeninos en el alpinismo
cuando yo empecé mi carrera estoy
hablando de los años 90 no había tantas
mujeres que se dedicaban alpinismo
[Música]
cuando nos enfrentamos a una montaña las
montañas no entienden de género entonces
Bueno pues una mujer puede estar
físicamente preparada también como como
un hombre no
[Música]
para mí siendo mujer era inviable pero
para mis compañeros que eran hombres que
tenían familia que tenían hijos que yo
he vivido embarazos de sus mujeres en el
campo base han dado a luz sus mujeres
cuando estábamos en expediciones no ha
habido ningún problema o sea y en caso
en el caso mío en mi carrera deportiva
al ser madre
pues nunca pudo ser nunca pude tomar esa
decisión
[Música]